It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today, I'm your host of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us for our 150 foot episode!
150 foot!
BAU BAU!
It's funny how things just light.
I feel like it was the 150th episode just the other day.
It was.
That's how it is!
Well, for Ruffians joining us today, maybe for the first time, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Now please state your thoughts with the hashtag right now.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Moco-chan, are you expecting to see every Ruffian's paw?
Show me your phone.
Ruffians.
Well, Ruffians!
Let's go BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians don't wanna show Moco-chan their phone.
Why?
You gotta tweet the hashtag, right?
Yeah.
BAU BAU.
Maybe the Ruffians don't know what to tweet with it, Moco-chan.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
You're not on Twitter!
Well, you're here.
That's even better, so... BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Wow, it's the middle of the week, Ruffians!
How's the week been going?
Going?
It's going!
It's Wednesday!
You made it.
You know, after Wednesday comes Thursday.
Thursday's usually much better than Wednesday and then it's Friday.
It's half past now.
It's been a good week, ruff week?
It's been pretty good?
Sleepy.
We'll do our best to make you have a better day today!
Moco-chan!
Shall we get to our first exciting news of the day?
Shall we make it better?
It's sort of questionable.
Questionable?
What do you mean, Moco-chan?
There's been another Pero Sighting.
How is Pero better?
I didn't see it.
Well, let's see where Pero has spotted the Moco-chan.
That's a very fluffy, but nasty cafe latte.
I don't know, I think nasty is correct, but fluffy... I don't know.
I think it's time... You know, take that spoon.
You stomp it in there and you go stir, stir, stir, stir!
Yeah, well you know, you could take two spoons and you could just go right in the middle of a pattern.
Rip them apart with them!
Why?
Which is better?
Yah!
Woah, yah, cool, yah!
That's the way to do it, right?
Do it very slowly.
Why would you save him?
No, no, no.
Rippin' tail!
Rippin' tail, yah!
Yah!
No Ruffians!
We're just trying to protect your smile, you know?
And sometimes it's rough, right?
Yeah.
Just sometimes, huh?
Ruffians, you seem... Whip and tear, whip and tear!
Whip and tear!
A perilous day keeps the doctor away?
I mean... I don't think that sounds right.
But it doesn't sound wrong, necessarily.
We haven't asked the doctor.
What about FUWAMOCO at the day?
The day?
A day keeps the doctor away.
Huh?
That sounds better, no?
Maybe.
Yeah.
Apple, we're not apples!
We're demon dogs!
Yeah.
Well, Ruffians, it's time to drink up your nasty happy latte here.
Get rid of it.
Okay.
BAU BAU!
Yeah.
Our heads are apple shaped, huh?
Huh?
Apple shaped!
Not apple FUWAMOCO.
Huh?
I guess I could sort of see where this dumb crumbs always sort of went the whole game.
We're demon dogs, not fruits, okay?
Not an apple.
No.
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
Although apples are tasty, but not as tasty as pondois.
Monday was big news!
Ruffians was a big, big milestone within hololive the other day!
Wow.
Hoshomari of hololive Gen 3 found that she reached 4 million subscribers on YouTube!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Deserved!
Yes!
Absolutely!
Amazing!
You know, Mari-senpai, she's always inspiring us with her creativity.
Her work as an idol and a musician too.
You know, just her...
Overwhelmingly, uh, what's the word for it?
Unique personality!
It's so negative!
I love it!
Unique personality.
But you know, we really really look up to her.
Yeah!
But we know how hard she works too.
Yeah.
You know, it's a very very relative milestone after her first solo live last year too.
And you know, it's a 4 million milestone.
Just a couple days ago, she released a fully animated music video for one of her new songs from last year.
Yeah, from her album.
A Honey Money World Densetsu no Yoru.
Honey Money World, right?
Sticky Money?
I know, as usual, it's a super deluxe animated video with fluid animation!
It has a bit of a nostalgic feel to it too!
I don't know, it's just, every video is a work of art!
How did she do it?
It's a catchy song too!
I like how an essential senpai song sounds.
A bit, what's the word?
Spicy?
Spicy!
Catchy!
No, it's a little more like a spicy vacation sound.
I feel like it's very, you know how Senchou-senpai Pirates feel.
Yeah.
Exactly right!
I have a honeymoon almost stuck in my head now.
I don't know, every single song is just amazing.
Thank you so much Senchou-senpai for always being there for us to look up to.
We'll continue doing our best too!
But waiting for you!
And I can't wait for what comes next too.
BAU BAU!
Senchou-senpai, she said she's aiming for 5 million now.
Mio-senpai!
She announced her new album "My Sparkle."
It'll be releasing on August 20th.
I think pre-orders have started now.
And her solo live "Our Sparkle" will be happening on September 10th at Pia Arena!
I'm so excited!
Another album from Mio-senpai!
We really really love Miyo-senpai's singing voice.
You know howling is a classic, but Yakko Tsushin just always makes me feel good.
I'm really looking forward to this new album.
I was taking a peek the other day at the songs too, and all the amazing creators she's working with too.
Mio-senpai has a great voice.
Mio-senpai is so kind too.
Howling is your favorite hololive song.
Howling is so good.
We're so excited and we'll be definitely there watching and cheering on when she howls.
TRIGGER
So much music!
Look at the album right there!
Too cool!
I'm excited for it too you know!
Right!
So many amazing content going on this year hololive!
There's so much emotion to it.
She has a new song, Kiyopito!
Delicate and strong.
Her new song with Teddy Boy!
So many things to listen to and check out!
And also too!
Also it's not just that!
Okayu-senpai has a solo live coming up too!
May 28th!
Not too far!
May 28th at Pier Arena!
Persona Respect!
Persona Respect, yes!
Three solo lives!
So many!
Right!
It's a busy year for senpai!
They don't stop coming!
No they don't!
FUWAMOCO we love solo lives so!
We get to see so many amazing performances from our senpai!
I'm excited but also!
In addition to that, there's one more!
Gamers is gonna be holding New Cho-Cho-Cho Gamers Fest at Saitama Super Arena.
And it's gonna be two days, on July 5th and July 6th.
But FUWAMOCO are also gonna be there as guests!
We're super honored and really excited!
I wonder what it's gonna be like.
Why is it so many?
We almost forgot about it!
Why?
It's unforgettable!
Right!
Cho-cho-cho gave us!
I'm so excited.
It's gonna be so much fun.
Right!
And we're gonna be there along with Subaru-senpai and Mikocchi-senpai!
We are FUWAMOCO!
FUWAMOCO!
I hope it's gonna be okay.
It's not gonna get too chaotic, is it?
Will there be online streaming tickets?
There is gonna be online streaming tickets for Cho-Cho-Cho Gamers!
So please check it out as well there!
What is Cho-Cho-Cho Gamers?
Gamers Fest!
It's a special festival with gamers!
You know they play a bunch of games, a whole bunch of different special plans!
But you'll have to find out, it's a little bit different for me to say.
A solo live where there's a lot of music being performed!
You know, it's gamers first!
Gaming!
So... We'll all have to look forward to it and find out what happens, huh?
BAU BAU!
I'm just so excited, you know!
So many solo lives already announced and happening this year!
You know...
What's happening in hololive?
It's exciting!
BAU BAU!
But I feel like we've been really lucky.
Because we've had lots of chances to be able to chat with Mio-senpai recently.
And actually the other day, we even got a morning phone call from Mio-senpai!
Mio-senpai called us very early in the morning.
I was very very sleepy still.
Moco-chan, you're a little bit awake.
A bit awake.
I had this waking up for a while.
Should I get up now?
Oh, you should get up now!
Get up now!
It's very hard to wake up recently, Ruffians.
I'm sure you understand.
Are you feeling like that right now?
Huh?
Moco-chan, can you wake the Ruffians up like you wake me up?
Oh, you have to get up now!
You have to get up now!
If you don't get up, I'm not gonna get up!
I have to get up, okay?
Moco-chan, I'm just... I'm awake!
I'm just gonna stretch here!
I'm just stretching, okay?
No stretching!
You have to get up!
It's okay, Moco-chan.
Just... No, you can't just... You can't just stand stretching, okay?
You have to get up.
I'm not awake.
BAU BAU.
Get up.
You should go.
That looks like stretching to me.
Yeah.
That's an excuse, Moco-chan.
I'm just... I'm just stretching, okay?
Give me a moment.
I'm just stretching.
I don't know why that's been waiting for so long, huh, Moco-chan?
Take the comments!
Okay, that's a way to get hated, okay?
That's anger.
That's anger!
And then you get a FUWAMOCO that's like... That's what mama puppy used to do.
That's what mama puppy does.
And then FUWAMOCO are grumpy.
Angry puppies.
Right in the morning.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Blankets, pots and pans.
Wrong paw!
Exactly!
It starts off the very wrong paw!
I'm just gonna go back to sleep harder because now I'm grumpy.
Yes, exactly!
No blankets, I don't care.
Pots and pans, I don't care.
I'm gonna go back to sleep harder.
But luckily, that wasn't the case with Miyo-chan's paw.
We had a very nice chat.
We chatted about what's first for us.
I wish Mio-senpai could wake us up every morning.
I feel much more energized and ready to go.
FUWAMOCO!
I'm hungry.
Do you want breakfast?
I want breakfast from Mio-senpai.
You have to wake up to Mio.
I'm very lucky for bees.
But I think this is also the first place that Ruffians can ever listen to
Sleepy.
Very sleepy voice, FUWAMOCO.
She's yours in meetings.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
We so like you!
Wow!
Awesome!
There is some interesting information!
Moco-chan is very excited about this!
Wow!
Poruru-oneechan!
She revealed in the...
Mio.
Super.
Miko.
The legend.
Life advice.
She revealed that she's been having a very fulfilled life at the gym recently.
Mico-chan is very happy, right?
She said that she's having lots of fun going to the gym and swimming.
That's what happens when you go to the gym and you swim.
Yeah.
Swimming.
She said she went swimming for a few hours.
Yeah.
I was imagining though, what kind of swimsuit do you think she swims in?
I feel like, you know, like the active style swimsuit.
A one-piece.
A one-piece with the back that's kind of open.
Yeah.
And the straps.
A bit high-legged-ish.
A bit high-legged?
A bit, a bit.
Does it have lots of colourful stripes, Moco-chan?
No, no.
Vertical stripes?
No.
Horizontal stripes?
Ruffles?
No.
What colour is it?
It's very simple.
It's too early to be imagining Pororori-chan in a swimsuit.
A floral pattern.
No.
No shimo shimo.
Yeah.
I can imagine her diving.
One of the diving boys.
Like a dolphin.
Yeah.
Well, I share all my experience so far.
Transfer's right.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
I'll go back to the gym for a little.
Ume-chan!
It's never too early to be talking about swimsuits.
Well, Ruffians.
Swimsuits.
Recently, I noticed.
I'm clear.
I don't understand why.
The golden swimsuits.
What is that thing?
Huh?
What is this trend?
Ruffians!
Heck yeah!
Huh?
You know there's lots of them in Tsukumizu.
Yes!
Navy Tsukumizu.
White Tsukumizu.
White Tsuk
We look like we're like, lemon flavored or something.
Like we're ice cream.
I feel like we look like trophies.
Trophies!
FUWAMOCO trophies!
Is that what the golden bathing suit does?
Why not silver bathing suit?
It looks good on us!
Thank you, but... the clothes are... the hair...
It's for high visibility for safety!
For safety?
That's the reason!
Maybe if you go to like a night pool?
Not because it's Golden Week, like the Ruffians have been mentioning!
A night pool!
Because for Golden Week!
I don't think that's for visibility, Moco-chan.
Who wears socks in swimsuits?
Everybody should.
It's my safety!
So Ruffians!
You know, when you make sure that you go out for your walk, like today I went on a walk, make sure you wear your visibility golden scoomies, okay?
And that way nobody can miss you!
Go on it!
You wear one!
You wear the golden scoomies!
I feel like I can't keep up with the trends.
Maybe this is okay.
BAU BAU!
Is this how we start off the day?
It's FUWAMOCO Morning, that kind of show, Moco-chan.
It's everything.
FUWAMOCO Morning is everything.
Well, Moco-chan, I'm feeling kind of... off.
Now that there's so much bathing suit talk.
Why?
Can you help with that?
Maybe.
Bofit, are you feeling off?
Silliness.
Well, I'll do my best, but I can't promise anything.
Okay, Moco-chan!
Ruffians!
It's that time again!
It's time for another Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me, Mococo!
Ruffians!
I see you there!
You know, you've been doing your best every day, right?
Right!
Recently!
Every day!
Actually, maybe you've been even
Putting in more than irregular 100%!
Even doing 200%!
And maybe pushing yourself way past your best.
No?
Maybe no one notices it when it all goes for granted by others.
But what matters the most is that you know yourself how hard you're working, okay Ruffians?
Most importantly, you need to make sure that you're happy and that you're not overdoing it, okay?
Make sure to look after yourself first and foremost.
And you know, maybe it's time to take a moment to do something just a little special and get a good recharge.
Okay!
Make sure to rest when you need to!
Do your best!
Ganbatte de!
Bye bye!
FUWAMOCO.
Ruffians!
Let's take a look at who our Doggie of the Day is today!
Our Doggie of the Day is... Today's Doggie of the Day is... Today's two doggies!
We have Ria and Moe!
Mama!
Two little fluffballs!
They look like little puppy angels!
They're shining!
Those ears!
Little triangle fluffy ears.
Pink and blue colors.
Kawaii!
Oh, I wonder where that inspiration was taken from, huh?
But you know, that's so amazing that you added them into your family!
It just grew so much happier now!
BAU BAU!
I know, I'm sure there's a lot more of a course now, a course of BAU BAUs going on.
How does Roya Roya Bow Bow?
Roy first.
I feel like Roy is probably very energetic.
Bow Bow Bow Bow Bow!
Bow Bow Bow Bow!
Very talkative Roya.
Roya.
Maybe a bit more.
Bow Bow.
Cute.
It sounds like they are singing a song all the time.
Together I'm sure they are always singing.
They're super cute.
Very precious.
And you know, they're brand new to your family.
And I'm sure that they're still adjusting, maybe making little mistakes here and there.
But just know, they'll grow into the best doggies ever, okay?
Yeah, you know, even if there's little mistakes, it's okay.
They're still learning.
So you know, make sure to give them lots of head pats too, okay?
Welcome to the family, boy over here!
BAU BAU!
So cute!
Ruffians, you're getting those paws up there.
Some fresh air too, right?
Well, today I went on a walk with this Ruffian man.
De-den!
A nice walk on the tree.
Such a pretty tree!
It's Moco-chan pink!
Last look at the tree before finishing another semester.
Congratulations!
Is it that time?
I guess it's that time, you know.
All of a sudden.
Wish it wasn't easy, but you did it!
And you know, I'm sure that this beautiful tree will be looking forward to when you come back for more learning at the end of the summer time.
Although it might be a little bit more green.
Meet you at the Mococo Tree!
The Mococochi it shall be.
Yes, it is now named the Mococochi.
It reminds me of Fuwawa because it's so fluffy.
Wow, it will be the Mococochi, yeah.
But good luck and enjoy your break!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Next we have our Question of the Day.
Today's Question of the Day is... FUWAMOCO De-den!
There has been an ongoing conspiracy theory amongst certain Ruffians that Mococo and Pero are actually one and the same.
I think you have no evidence.
This is completely baseless.
Pero.
You like this question?
Damn!
I think this is offensive.
I think this is false.
Ruffians, are you okay?
Baseless accusations.
Accusations.
Yes.
Wild conspiracy.
Conspiracies are good, Ruffians.
Moco-chan is fuzzy!
No, there is no evidence!
Pero's nasty!
You said the evidence, there's no evidence.
Pero's a mentor.
That can't be.
I see Pero and Moco-chan together.
Ruffians.
Faceless.
Are you okay?
I don't know about this.
I know things are rough, you know.
It's a Wednesday, Wednesday's blah.
But...
I guess I'll forgive you, maybe.
I could.
I could forgive you.
Maybe you need to keep glasses?
Glasses are nice!
Don't be embarrassed.
It's okay.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians, for all your submissions!
Remember, you already used the hashtag #FWMCMORNING once today, right?
So now it's easy!
Now you can just send us your questions.
Thank you, Ruffians, for all your questions on Twitter earlier today!
But you can also send us your doggy holidays!
Your walks, you know, it's getting so nice out there!
And then maybe your Pero Sighting too.
Although, uh... Maybe get glasses first.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
And for our next team!
We have... De-den!
FUWAMOCO is this a... Mistake?
Mistake?
I... No, it's not because I... Ruffians!
For the first time ever we kinda overslept.
It's been rough with you doing a lot of recordings and homework, but... New song!
New-ish song.
But with the Doggy Pack, finally!
Finally, finally!
We're gonna be having our after party for our new cover song!
Yes, it is in English, so please check it out!
Our first cover song in English!
Thank you, Mofus, for understanding.
It means a lot to us because we're both panicking a little bit.
But now we'll have a really nice comfy chat all together.
And be able to talk about all my feelings and thoughts.
And everything that went into Christmas.
Thank you Ruffians!
Thank you FUWAMOCO!
And we'll take a look at our schedule.
And we'll continue.
But FUWAMOCO continues with a big finale on Saturday, DE.
We hope that you'll continue to join us and the rest of hololive English all together for our adventures in Labrador.
And on Sunday, it's Narada's very first birthday!
And we're gonna be over on her channel.
On our channel!
We're gonna be playing Among Us!
All together with our whole Ien-senpai boy!
And celebrating now it is birthday!
Yeah, first birthday!
Been a while since we all played Among Us, right?
Let's see what happens.
Really great first time.
BAU BAU!
And for the Ruffians joining us in the Oikai today, your FUWAMOCO word is... BAU BAU MOUNTAINS AND VALLEY!
Thank you so much Ruffians for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Together!
BAU BAU!
Chiyo.
Diamonds.
BAU BAU!
Kurori.
Waibun.
BAU BAU!
Kenshin 52.
Kehojo.
BAU BAU!
Dakota Brickhead.
Lillian.
BAU BAU!
1315 Jimmy.
Lilydose.
BAU BAU!
MyDestiny.
Shawn Gillis.
BAU BAU!
Kizu.
What am I supposed to do if it doesn't move?
Shikichi.
BAU BAU!
Deshita is BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!
Don't go to bed!
Don't go in the bed!
BAU BAU!